[Music]
we can get stranger things season two is
finally here
freedom I can talk about it et got some
advice from the cast on how to binge
watch the Netflix series at their la
première in your professional opinion do
you think this stranger things fan
should binge it all at once or take
their time gosh I don't know how I feel
of I mean I it's very dangerous
binging I'm very guilty of it and it but
you know you do you don't move you you
know you sit there and suddenly the days
go by I definitely recommend someone
told me that the way they watch their
shows as they watch all the episodes
except for the last one and then wait
for the next season to come out and
watch the last one before so they kind
of get like it slide into it easily if
you want to bender than binge it I
personally like to space things out
though I like to savor them I like yeah
all in one and then it's over you know
but if you're gonna do it stay fueled
there should be good snacks involved and
I think you should pace it out well you
know like if you have if you have work
to the next day I think you should you
know watch like 1 or 2 tonight watch
like a couple more tomorrow night and
then sort of just space it out don't let
it get in the way of your like passion
but if it is your passion to watch it
then you should do what everyone depends
on what day of the week it is if it's
like on Mondays you'd be like spaced out
you don't like because well you gotta go
to work the next day
retired but I recommend you watch it on
a Friday I did it probably three four
three or something like that
honestly I maybe would do it like that
that was pretty good it was kind of like
three kind of marathons but I assume
some people are gonna watch it all
Friday like skip work it's very exciting
so excited for you guys to see it
[Music]
you
[Music]